So there's no easy way out.
It's not an easy out,
it's just pure cynicism to
associate that idea with,
with an easy out,
it's not.
But there is that positive idea that
it's continually represented is that the
individuals,
the source of moral choice and the
individual is prone to genuine error and
temptation in a believable
and realistic way.
But that that doesn't sever
the relationship between
the individual and the
divine and the possibility
of further growth.
And then I would say,
well thank God for that
because without that,
like who would have a chance?
Right?
Who would have a chance.
And so the idea that the day that
he has presented the infinite,
let's say as presented in
the Old Testament is merely
judgmental is definitely
wrong and is in fact something that
you can contend with and Argen with.
Oh,
I'll close with one thing.
One of the things that I learned while
I was going through this was the meaning
of the name Israel.
Cause Jacob eventually gets named Israel.
And,
and I'm jumping ahead a little bit to the,
to the next lecture,
but Israel and so he's also the father
of Israel and the father of the 12 sons
who make up the 12 tribes of Israel.
But what Israel means is
he who struggles with God.
And that's such an interesting
idea because it's again,
a psychological idea.
And that's why I said earlier that it
isn't obvious in the old testament what it
means to believe in God
because what Jacob does,
his struggle with God.
And I think that that's a really good
characterization of an ethical life
because if you're trying
to lead an ethical life,
that's what you're doing is you're,
you're struggling.
Like blind belief isn't helpful because
you don't know what you're believing in.
Like it's just not that helpful.
But if you're possessed by,
by the desire to orient yourself properly,
but also confused by the,
by the existential structure of the world,
which we all are then,
then what you're doing when you're trying
to orient yourself properly in life is
struggling ethically.
And Jacob actually gets quite hurt.
He wrestles with God literally,
and God dislocates his,
his,
his thigh.
And so,
you know,
the idea there is watch the hell out,
right?
The thing that you're
contending with is powerful,
although you can contend with it.
That's the thing that's so interesting,
but you know,
you do it at some genuine peril,
which I think is exactly right.
But the idea that Israel,
so there's Israel,
the state,
let's say in Israel,
the promised land and all of that.
But there's this more important idea,
which is again,
a psychological idea,
which is the state of Israel,
which is the promised land is the state
that everyone who wrestles with God
exists in.
And that's not happy,
naive belief in,
you know,
uh,
an eternally blessed afterlife.
It's not that it's not a wish fulfillment,
it's,
it's to be actively engaged in
life and the difficulties of life,
right?
And trying to find the path because
that's what wrestling with God is,
is trying to find the path.
And that seems to me what belief means
fundamentally in the Old Testament,
perhaps in the new testament as well,
is that belief is expressed
in trying to find the path.
And that's an ethical struggle.
And it's a real struggle.
It's the struggle of life.
So as long as you're willing
to engage in that struggle,
then hypothetically you
have the divine behind you.
And so
I believe that.
I think that's true because the other
thing I see is that the people who set
things right so that the,
the,
the horrible forces of cosmic destruction
don't do us in the people who are
trying to set things right are the ones
that are struggling ethically and so,
and that there is a
redemptive element to that.
And I don't think there's any
way of being cynical about that.
So.
Well,
so thank you.